first pitch on this mother's day a very
special one
for astros moms lori castro
olga lydia castillo julie guriel's mom
la ste altuve and jackie bregman not
only is olga lydia yuli's mom
also lourdes guriel's mom he's got the
dual jersey going
on the mound for the astros today
right-hander zach frankie 2-1 a 3.76 cra
and seven starts
marcus simeone leading off for the third
straight game 3-2 pitch grounded towards
robel garcia
starting in the major leagues for the
first time ever at shortstop
in fact he hasn't started at any level
since 2013 at short when he was in class
a
but getting a chance to play for carlos
correa today and gets tested on the
first batter
one out no one on for the blue jays
shortstop bo bachette
swing and a miss down goes beshet
over shut down on strikes and frankie
picks up the first two outs of this game
i'll bring up vladimir guerrero the
ground ball and two hops to alex bregman
jackie sun makes the throw across to
olga lydia's son
and that's how the first inning ends on
mother's day
zach grinkiel one two three first here
is pearson to make his
season debut against a good
houston astro lineup and here is julie
guriel first baseman julie batting 339
that's fifth in the al
again the 1-2 and a slider is
popped up into shallow left center field
grichik is there
and pearson will get out of it a base
hit a walk but nothing across
in his return to the big leagues runner
at third
and one out no score in the top of the
second and now it's kevin bizio hitting
215.
two and two of the count and a big
strikeout
pull the string on kevin vigil picks up
strikeout number two
needing that swing and miss with the
runner at third base less than two outs
and
grenkey going to that chain jump bring
up lourdes
jr frankie trying to work his
way around the lead-off double ball in
the right field playable for tucker a
few steps back
and puts it away grenkey does work
around a lead off double by tay oscar
hernandez
nicely done zach we head to the bottom
of the second scoreless
so the bases are loaded with tucker at
third garcia at second and altuve at
first for michael brantley who walked
his first time
upstairs ball four bases loaded walk
will score the first run of the game
michael brantley with an rbi it's one
nothing astros
pierce still has to find a way to try to
get out of this inning facing alex
bregman now
the 2-2 on the way and a swing and a
ball
in the air back of short beshette is
there
will make the catch and the inning is
finally over on third but shet on first
base
and now you've got to face vladimir
guerrero jr
slow curveball 68 miles and that's the
one that's
the one you're looking for blatty
guerrero jr goes down swinging a couple
of hits two left
on for guriel he walks jogs down to
first base with one out here's tucker
sharply hit through the legs of telez
all the way down to the corner
uli guriel will get to third kyle tucker
will get to second now yuli being waved
around
here comes the throw not in time rbi
triple for kyle tucker it's a
two-nothing lead
this ball smoked at 102.1 miles an hour
past rowdy teles robel garcia the batter
there's a sharply hit ground ball base
hit robel garcia
with his second rbi of the year and kyle
tucker scores to make it three nothing
astro
he will flip to grenkey covering zach
just gets to the bag in time ahead of
kevin biggio
that was dangerous on both sides of the
play
nearly initially thought about a double
play before he flipped it to zach
zach couldn't find the bag initially
yeah he had to look back to get the ball
and he was expecting that next step
lourdes guriel flew out to right as last
time up runner on second base
a little flare into center field coming
on straw he's going to get there
for the final out of the inning frankie
gets through the fourth inning
bottom half of the fourth inning jose
altuve will lead things off against joel
piamps
that ball's driven deep to right field
jose altive
third home run of the year altuve's mom
laste
in attendance today shoots throughout
the first pitch
and altuve hits a home run the other way
fastball away just go with it now duvet
showing some of that power going to the
opposite field here at minute maid park
the wave towards mom in attendance
now anthony k comes on tabby here in the
fourth runners on first and second for
kyle tucker
tucker drives one deep to right field
that ball is way up there in the second
deck
three run home run kyle tucker
on a 3-0 pitch and the astros double
their lead
they add three more to their lead it's
now seven to nothing
picked a pitch out over the plate he got
it
and he barreled it up and launched it
rowdy toles coming up for the second
time today
and now a swing and a ball hit a long
way to right field
a hanging curve ball that rowdy teles
hits out
and the blue jays are on the board now
trailing 7-1
outstanding power i love how he waited
on that breaking ball recognized it
right away out of his hand
two on and nobody out for the blue jays
in the top of the fifth bo bashat
stands in one for two with a single
and bechet gets a ball hits it a long
way to left field off the wall on the
fly
maguire's going to come in to score
simeon right behind him
on a two-run double by buchet and it is
seven to three
and well that'll bring vladimir guerrero
[Music]
and now he loops one down the right
field line for a base hit
and rounding third heading home is
beshette
guerrero keeps the line moving and it's
seven to four
and that will be it for zach frankie he
will not go more than four innings ryan
abreu takes over
95 96 out of the arm of brian abreu
sharply hit to bregman two out two they
for one they turn the double play on
grichik
brian abreu comes in out of the bullpen
and gets the job done
here's michael brantley couple of walks
and a ground out for the astros left
fielder
first and second one out astro seven in
the blue jays four
runner goes again 3-2 again curveball
in the air left center field and it'll
split the outfielders
plays it on a bounce maldonado around
third
throw to the plate and they got him
even with the running start with two
outs and a full count
maldonado cannot score from first on the
double
and the inning is over andre scrub takes
over
in the eighth inning oscar hernandez is
the batter
hammer time strikeout with the curveball
scrub gets hernandez looking biggio down
in the count quickly
hammertime got him on the curveball too
legit
too legit to quit andre scrum has
retired 11
in a row over his last three outings
ryan presley on the trying to get the
final three out
danny jansen will bad got him presley a
one
two three nine couple of strikeouts in
the mix
the astros win it seven to four taking
two out of three from the toronto blue
jays